This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. I'm sitting here in the studio with my dog. Actually, for those of you who don't know, I foster failed. I have a dog now. Big life updates on that one, but I've been getting warmed up for this topic because it
is going to be a supreme deep dive into what is slowly becoming, I would say, a defining, but also exhausting part of modern dating in our 20s. That is the talking stage, that kind of murky, unlabeled limbo where you're messaging someone like every single day, you're flirting, you're sharing things but you're not dating. Maybe you haven't even met in person yet. You're not really sure where things are going or if they're going anywhere at all. Yet it's this strange thing where this person has become part of your daily life. You're kind of expecting things from them. So why do we even have a talking stage? And why has it become so psychologically intense as a recent? We're going to break down the psychology.
behind this today. Specifically, what makes a talking stage so compelling? Why do we get attached without even knowing someone? How do we protect ourselves from emotionally investing in people that we are interested in while still being open to communicating? Lots of big questions there. We're also going to look at the personality traits of people who extend and love a prolonged talking stage, perhaps the people you should be avoiding and the role of certain traits like commitment readiness, intermittent reinforcement. And also, this is a big message for this episode, why playing games, game playing in the talking stage is basically going to instantaneously mean that you are not going to be in a relationship with that person.
we need to be pursuing authenticity, especially in this current dating environment where, you know, dating apps give us the illusion of endless choices and endless possibilities and no one wants to commit, no one wants to go on dates. Being authentic and direct about what you want is the only way. So if you have ever felt stuck in a never-ending talking stage, you are not alone. I have been there, done that, got the t-shirt. as have many other people in their 20s, but we're going to unpack it today, all of the psychology, as well as a little bit of a guide to getting through the talking stage, how to find closure when
the talking stage perhaps ends, and my hard and fast rules for exactly how long you should be chatting with someone before you go on a date. So with all of that in mind, stay with us. So I want to begin by kind of defining some parameters here. The talking stage, stage for me. I know it has a few different ways of being thought about, but for me, it is the stage before you officially go on a date. It's the lead up. It's the preamble. It may also sometimes last past the first, I would say two dates if there is long gaps between when you are going on dates in which you are talking. But it's really that period where you're on each other's radar, but you're not consistently dating.
You're not planning for dates, date one or date two or date three. So essentially, the defining feature of a talking stage is you are spending the majority of your time communicating with them over messenger, over text online, and not much time making concrete plans or seeing each other in real life, which I think we can all agree is really preferable. Let's talk about this. Why do we even have a talking stage to begin with if most people's experience of it is awful and less than pleasant? Well, essentially, the talking stage is part of what we call our modern dating script.
So the modern dating script is basically the storyline we all expect a romance to follow. It's the script that influences how you believe you should interact at certain times, what your timeline should be, And it kind of goes like this. You cross paths, you spend some time talking to figure each other out, then you go on a date, go on a few more dates, wait a few months, make sure they're not seeing other people, make sure you're not seeing other people, and hopefully you end up in a relationship. During each stage or chapter of that, there are different ways of communicating and interacting with each other that we kind of pick up from media, culture, society at large. Of course, ending up in a relationship, most of us would be able to tell this is not always the case. At every stage of this script or this narrative, there is a way for things to get complicated. The talking stage is no different.
In some cultures and countries, like there is no talking stage. That's just not part of their dating script. You know, the only talking that gets done is asking someone to go out immediately. But it's definitely becoming a more prominent part of how we view dating. And actually, this generation, more than any other, take longer to decide if they want to date someone. A 2024 study, it was one of the first to really investigate the talking stage. It found that the talking stage is what they would call a new relationship construct. It is something that has really only emerged in the past 15 years before 20, I think it was like,
2010, 2012, the talking stage was not really part of our vocab. It wasn't really a term. It wasn't really part of the early dating period. The reason why people in this generation are spending more time in the talking stage is because this period allows us to assess compatibility. Yes, it does allow us to test if we have the same interests, if we communicate the same, if we have the spark. it does allow us to tell, is this person a total asshole? But it's also being used to really protect us against pain and to also help us avoid the emotional sunk costs that would occur if we just dived in headfirst into a relationship.
That is typically what we think a talking stage is meant to help us do, but this same study really examined that an increase in the pool of potential partners has facilitated this rides in the talking stage. The main culprit being dating apps. People want to keep options open because this availability of other people is so much more obvious. It's just this huge pressure
that there is always going to be someone else out there who could potentially be better for you. So people want to keep options open. People want to not settle down as quickly or, you know, choose someone. And the paradox or irony of this is that normally they're actually missing out on the person who was right in front of them who may be really great because you keep thinking that someone better out there exists when the person that you were thinking of is completely made up.
It's a classic example of the paradox of choice. We have too many options. Dating apps are creating the illusion of infinite possibilities. that makes it harder for people to commit because it makes the possibility of something better seem a lot more real. I think what's hard about this as well is that the talking stage and the emergence of this
has only happened in the last 15 years. And yet we're still comparing our stories of dating to the love stories of before. And we're also facing confusion from relatives and family members who have entirely different, perspectives on dating from when they were finding love. And so the stigma feels very severe, but it's because our reality is just simply different.
Our families don't understand. They think that dating is the way it was when they were getting to know people. And so we're facing this dual frustration of being like, well, I wish it was, but also it's not. So understand that this is just something we have to deal with. So this is what I believe. I'm going to give you a hard and fast rule here. I believe the talking stage should be entirely about information gathering and honesty. Nothing more.
I also think it should not last longer than one month. Maximum. Maximum. At one month, you've got to press pause or you've got to make plans ASAP. It's like when you go for a job and you have that initial interview to see if you vibe. That's what a date is meant to be. the talking stage. You know, imagine doing a job interview, but it was entirely over email. Like, you don't really get to know someone. And you don't really get to know someone over just texting either.
Like, there's so many ways that they can create the illusion or a perception of who they are. You need to be on that, on that date. Like, you need to be in person talking for real. You know, I get so frustrated at today's dating culture that is so quick to, waste someone else's time in the name of getting to know someone without ever actually taking them on a date, especially when you're secretly comparing them to other options that you have. You know, I know we don't want to regret our choice of romantic partner. It is a big and significant decision. It does determine a lot of our happiness.
But how unfair. How unfair to just keep someone on the line and just keep chatting to them and never taking them on a date because what, you're waiting for someone else to come along. If you have to question it, if you have to question it before you even met them in person, I think you have to give the other person the kindness of letting them go and letting them go and find someone who is 100% yes about just wanting to meet them and see where things go.
Maybe not 100% yes about the relationship, but it's because you haven't gone on a date yet. Like the talking stage should only be a, about information. You are not meant to be making any decisions. The decisions should only be made based on the dates and the real life exposure you have. I truly just think we are just overthinking this. We're overthinking the talking stage. I see people in like three months, six months, sometimes even year-long talking stages. And it's just like you're waiting for a caterpillar to turn into a butterfly and realizing the entire time that you had a stick. You know, that's what that
feels like. There is a certain profile of individuals I see who I think really enjoy the extended talking stage more than others. And they often display the following traits. These are the people that if you don't like a long talking stage like I do. Like I don't. I'm sorry I should say, I don't like a long talking stage. I never have. I never will. This is who you need to look up for. Firstly, the first kind of person who loves a talking stage and never a date is someone who is low in a trait known as commitment readiness. So this was a trait first identified by a paper published in 2018. And the paper basically found that we all exist on a spectrum of either wanting or not
wanting commitment. And at any point, we are somewhere on that scale between high commitment readiness, which means like you are ready to go, you are either in a committed relationship or like the next person who comes along, you're going to grab them and you're going to make it happen, or your low in commitment readiness, meaning you don't want to be attached to anyone. So people who are low on commitment readiness do not want a relationship. They may still want intimacy. They may still want entertainment, dopamine from the pursuit.
But they are also the ones who are most likely going to keep you in the talking stage for longer because they understand that once they move you into the dating zone, own. Then they're going to have to deal with the questions of our commitment and this going somewhere. The talking stage is a great pen power situation. It's a great limbo situation. People do shift up and down the scale, by the way, of commitment readiness. If you've just broken up with someone, you're probably very low on the commitment readiness scale. But if you, you know, just got married, you're obviously very high. So maybe this person will change. Great news for you, though. You don't have to wait for that.
There is no point you're trying to force them to move up or down the scale. That is something that they can only do from themselves and because they want to. There's no point trying. You just need to move on. The other thing that talking stage proponents have in common is often an anxious, avoidant, ambivalent attachment style. They've been hurt before. The early childhood experiences have maybe taught them that closeness equals pain. And so they may keep you at arm's length as a way to put.
protect themselves emotionally from really investing in you. It doesn't mean they may not want more. They just can't bring themselves to initiate it. Again, that's a really hard situation. But at that point, I do think that you cannot wait around until their attachment style suddenly heals. Especially if they are not even willing to ask people on dates, it shows that unfortunately they do have a lot of work to do
themselves. And it's not like things are going to change once you're suddenly dating. Like the time where you should be most excited about a relationship is when you're first getting to know someone. And if they're not, well, that's not going to get better. The final trait I tend to notice, for those who love a talking stage, is a class of people called novelty seekers. Obviously, as humans, we have a baseline desire and in fact a need for newness, for novelty in our everyday lives. But some people find that this novelty is most satisfying to them when it comes in the form of human connection. So they are psychologically stimulated by the uncertainty of getting to know people,
the exploration, and the emotional novelty from talking stages. You know, talking stages are fun. They're exciting. Everything is new. You don't know anything about this person. They can be anything you want them to do. be. So they really enjoy that. They love that like flirtatious tension, that possibility, that potential. But when things start getting real, well, that can be the end of that. You know, the
high is done for them. The fun is done. There's nothing wrong with any of these things or the people who possess these traits. But if you are exhausted from another dead end talking stage, maybe it's possible that this profile of people are the people you keep meeting. These are the people who keep coming across, coming into your lives, either through dating apps or through friends or through wherever. Maybe these can act as red flags or kind of an early warning system for you that if someone is displaying these things, hey, maybe this isn't leading where you think it's going to be leading.
Maybe you nip it in the bud now. So this next big question we have that I'm very keen to answer, why is the talking stage so psychologically intense? Even when we know we should just be information seeking, even when we know we should kind of keep our guard up until we're actually getting to know them in person. So the reason it's so psychologically intense is that the entire situation and the entire emotional environment you are in is uncertain. And uncertain situations take more from us mentally than certain ones. We are constantly judging.
How much do I give? How much do I show? Do I text back? What do I say? Do they like me? Is this turning them off? Exhausting. And sometimes this can turn into some mind games, some dating games.
You know, the games we play in the talking stage, like they are like no other. But what one researcher has really argued is that games are actually quite destructive. to relationships. And actually the reason that we play them is for self-protection. It's not because we are trying to move something along. It's because we're trying to make sure that we aren't the first one who was hurt. If they're not messaging you back right away, then neither should you. Because you don't want to feel the fool.
If they're only sending you videos or one-word replies, you should do that as well. By matching their tone, we think that this will help us keep us less invest. But actually changing our behavior to meet theirs indicates the opposite. It indicates that we are invested enough to notice. It indicates that we are invested enough to not want to set them off or give them a reason to not talk to us. Just a reminder, you can never say the wrong thing to the right person. Please resist the urge to play games. Authenticity in these situations.
It is so key. I wish I had known that sooner. there are so many times when if I had just said what I meant and what I wanted to say, when I wanted to say it, I would have been able to figure out someone so much quicker and I would have been able to realize that they were never going to be what I was after. But all of this excessive thinking, the other thing that it does is it leaves our brain assuming, hey, well, this person must be important because we're constantly thinking about them. We're changing our behavior for them. so it makes the whole situation take on a much more serious tone. It implants them in our brain.
That is what makes it so hard to let go and so intense. The other reason it can be so psychologically intense, talking stages are by nature ambiguous, there aren't clear boundaries, but there's also so much potential. Then there's the concept of intermittent reinforcement. This is the same psychological mechanism that keeps people addicted to slot machines at the casino or like any form of gambling. You know, you don't win every time, but you win just enough to
stay hooked. You know, a good morning text one day and then the next day nothing. A very flirty conversation followed by them not say anything for three days. It creates a psychological reward loop that can feel very addictive. Of course, you know, at the core of this experience, again, I'm going to bring it up is the potential that it could turn into more. And that's really exciting. especially if you've been single for a while or you are getting really great vibes. And that leads to such an important question. How do you not get attached too quickly? I've been there when I was single.
Oh my goodness, I would find it so hard to not immediately plan for a future with someone when we'd only been talking for like a few days. It can be so hard to not think that everyone is the one. It can be so hard to keep up your standards and to not get hurt. So we're going to talk about the exact formula and things you need to do to keep that distance in the early stages when we return to stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what we. went down and tried to make sense of how we survived it.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real. real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lusby and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think a talking stage becomes particularly difficult when we get attached when we know we shouldn't. We get attached before we have any confidence that this is going to actually go in. anywhere. Rationally, this is very hard, right? Because we want to pump the brakes, but our mind, our heart, whatever it is, has other plans. And we feel very powerless over it. You know, this is what my experience was, I just couldn't help myself. My thoughts kept going back to that person. My behaviours automatically seemed to change. I would find myself idolizing the fantasy
of them, constantly checking my phone. And I would consciously be trying to. stop and I couldn't do it. This is also particularly hard, I think, if you're someone who is quite anxious, even a bit of a romantic, you know, who wouldn't chase after the possibility of love? Who doesn't want to fall for the idea that they could be seen and loved? That's what every person wants. It's only natural to have that opportunity right in front of us and to think about it and to want it even more. But when we do get attached too easily, it really has nothing to do with what happens to the other person, right?
Sometimes people worry about getting attached too quickly because they think it's going to scare them off. I think what we actually need to be worried about with this is the consequences that it might have for us and our own standards, our own well-being, our own state of mind, what we look past when we shouldn't. So this is what we need to do to just keep a bit of our sentiment.
One of my favorite studies of all time investigated the reason behind why we settled too soon, and it found that this often happens when we are bored or when the rest of our life has become quite stagnant. We don't feel like we have much else going on. The other factor is having a poor self-concept and feeling like this is as good as it's going to get, this is as good as I'll find, I may as well go for it. The way to count, out of racked this is to keep your life beyond dating, specifically beyond the people you're talking to, as interesting and vibrant and full as possible. Now, this has a few effects. It means you won't be bored, so we eliminate that. You won't be impressed by the bare minimum, but also
you'll have something else to think about, to keep you distracted. And the more you are passionate about in your solo life, in your independent life, I think the less you'll lower your standards for someone who doesn't absolutely contribute and expand what you already have. It's also really important to slow down the part of your brain that is bound to start fantasizing. This part of your brain is called the default mode network. It's responsible for dreaming, fantasy, memory, creativity. Its counterforce is our executive functioning. It's our rational mind, which can come into these fantasies.
scenarios and say, wow, that's pretty. That's very nice. But here's the cold hard truth. So the way to do this is I want you to deliberately call in your executive thoughts to notice when you're filling in gaps with idealized versions of who this person could be, not who they are. I want you to really be on the lookout for signs that you are emotionally overinvesting. And when you are making assumptions about who they are that is not supported, by evidence. So what we're going to try and do is date and connect, specifically talk, talk and connect based on data, not on daydreams.
So I want you to ask yourself, if you're still in the talking stage, do I like them? Or do I like the feeling of them being interested in me? Am I excited by the potential? Or am I actually enjoying this conversation? Am I investing too much in the what-ifs? Or is this person actually giving me a good sign? It can also help to really have these hard and fast rules for when you can and cannot do certain things with them,
can and cannot bring up certain topics to ensure you're not attaching too soon. First off, if you've never met this person, you are not going to share too much about your past dating history. You are not going to talk about big topics for you. You're not going to make future plans with them. You don't need to tell them about your dreams. You don't need to tell them out. You don't need to tell them too much about what's going on in your life. Because I think that can inadvertently bond.
哪些话题能聊、哪些话题不能聊，以此确保你不会投入得太快。首先，如果你从来没见过这个人，你就绝不应该过多分享你过去的恋爱史。你绝不应该讨论对你而言很大、很重的话题。你绝不应该和他们做未来的规划。你不需要跟他们诉说你的梦想。你不需要把这些告诉他们。你不需要向他们过多透露你生活中的近况。因为我觉得那会在无意中建立起一种联结。
When you start going on dates, yeah, that's fine. But talking stage, no. We, of course, also have the one month rule at one month they're out. There's also this fantastic principle called, and I think this comes up later on, but in general advice for not getting attached to quickly, it's called the three-date or three-encounter rule. which essentially states that you need to see people in three different contexts
当你开始真正约会时，是的，那没问题。但在暧昧试探阶段，绝不。当然啦，我们还有一个“一个月规则”：满一个月他们就得局。还有一个非常棒的原则，我想后面也会提到，不过总的来说，这是一个防止自己陷得太快的实用建议，它被称为“三次约会或三次见面规则”。其核心意思基本上是，你需要通过三种不同的场景去观察一个人，
before deciding if they're right for you. You need to see them sober. You need to see them around others and you need to see them when they're stressed. Obviously, like I said, comes in later on, but I think it's still mentally helpful for you to understand when you are allowed to commit and it's way down the line and try and combat the unconscious scarcity mindset that's probably sneaking in right now.
然后才能决定他们是否适合你。你需要看他们清醒时的样子。你需要看他们在社交场合的表现，还需要看他们在压力之下的反应。显然，就像我说的，这会在后面展开，但我觉得在心理层面上，它能帮你搞清楚什么时候你才被允许真正投入感情，这其实是很后面的事了，同时也能帮你对抗此刻可能正悄悄潜入你心中的、潜意识里的稀缺心态。
let me just say this. This is not the only person for you. There are more people who will be interested in you because you are endlessly fascinating. You give so much love to others. It's going to come back to you. This is just an information seeking exercise. And you have just as much control in this situation as they do. Remember, there's no winning here.
我只想说：这个人绝不是你的唯一选择。还会有更多人对你感兴趣，因为你是如此魅力无穷。你给予了他人那么多的爱。这些爱终究会回到你身上。这只是一次收集信息的练习。在这段关系中，你和他们拥有着同等的掌控权。记住，这里没有谁赢谁输。
There's also no losing. There's no game. this doesn't work out, that's because something better is coming for you. You just have to trust me when I say this. Showing up authentically and perhaps missing out, but knowing you missed out for the right reasons is better than, you know, dating someone and realizing that they have fallen for someone who was not you. They've fallen for someone who was appeasing them, who was doing things to make them more
这里也没有失败。这根本不是一场游戏。如果这段关系没成，那是因为有更好的人正在向你走来。当我说这话时，你必须选择相信我。以真实的自我去面对，哪怕可能因此错过，但只要你知道自己错得有理有据，这也总好过——你知道的——和某人约会到最后，却发现他们爱上的根本不是真正的你。他们爱上的只是那个曲意逢迎的你，那个为了让他们开心而做各种事的你，
comfortable, who was pretending to like things that they liked when really you didn't have anything in common. It's why honesty in these situations always the best policy, even just asking someone on a date if they're not doing it for you. Like, you want to get an answer? That's the best way to get it. Let's now talk about what happens when the talking stage doesn't work out. I think it is okay to grieve these situations. I think it is okay to acknowledge that this is hard. sometimes I do seriously believe that we're essentially in a stage of mourning, even though it might sound silly, we are mourning the endless potential of someone, of what they could have been, which is sometimes harder, because it's fed by the unknown rather than reality.
那个为了让他们更舒服而迎合他们、假装喜欢他们所喜欢的东西，到头来却发现你们其实毫无共同点的人。这就是为什么在这些情况下，坦诚永远是上上策，哪怕只是直接问一个对你没感觉的人要不要约会。比如，你想得到一个答案？这就是最好的获取方式。现在我们来聊聊，当暧昧试探阶段没能修成正果时，会发生什么。我觉得，为这些情况感到难过是完全正常的。我觉得，承认这很难受是完全没问题的。有时我甚至真的相信，我们其实正经历着一个类似哀悼的阶段，虽然听起来可能有点傻，但我们确实是在为某人身上那无限的可能性、为他们原本可能成为的样子进行哀悼。而且这种哀悼往往更难熬，因为它是由未知而非现实所喂养的。
It's what we call disenfranchised grief, grief that isn't necessarily acknowledged by society, grief that isn't necessarily large, but which still hurts, even if it doesn't feel. fit into the usual box of what we deserve to feel sad about. You know, when a relationship ends, you can kind of say, okay, well, it didn't work out for these reasons. We tried this. We did this. We just didn't have it. But with a talking stage, it is shrouded in all these what ifs. What if we had been given a chance? What if we just gone on that first day? You know, what if they'd just gotten to know me? Don't they see like, there's could have been something. That ambiguity is what makes this so hard to process.
这就是我们所说的“剥夺性悲伤”（disenfranchised grief）——一种不一定能被社会所承认的悲伤，一种不一定惊天动地，却依然隐隐作痛的悲伤，哪怕它并不符合我们认为“值得为之伤心”的传统定义。你知道，当一段正式的恋爱关系结束时，你大可以说：好吧，因为这些原因所以没能走下去。我们努力过了。我们尝试过了。只是我们真的不合适。但对于暧昧试探阶段而言，它却被重重“如果”所包裹。如果我们当时得到了一个机会呢？如果我们当时真的去约了第一次会呢？你知道的，如果他们当时愿意花时间真正了解我呢？难道他们看不出，我们之间明明是有可能的吗？正是这种模棱两可、暧昧不清，才让这一切如此难以消化。
It's not just the rejection. It's the disappointment of the potential that was wasted by someone else's indecisiveness or their own issues. So here's how we're going to find some closure. You don't need to block them, but you do need to implement some rules. My biggest piece of advice would just be just be straight up to say to them, hey, you know, since we're not going on a date, since this is kind of going nowhere, I'm not sure if this has been lost in translation, but I'm really only keen on being able to meet people in person
这不仅仅是关于被拒绝。这是那种因为别人的犹豫不决或自身问题，而白白浪费了原本可能性的巨大失落。所以，接下来我们要如何找回一些心理上的闭环（closure）。你不需要拉黑他们，但你确实需要设定一些规则。我给出的最大建议就是：直接跟他们挑明。告诉他们：“嘿，鉴于我们并没有真正去约会，鉴于这段关系基本没啥进展，我不知道是不是有什么误会，但我其实只想和人面对面地接触，
and actually get to know you. I know you don't want to waste my time. I don't want to waste yours either. So I think I'm going to focus on some other things and other people for a while. Really, you need to be direct. Use this as a polite excuse to essentially stop replying, stop interacting, maybe even mute them, move them to the unseen folder on Messenger or Instagram.
然后真正去了解彼此。我知道你不想浪费我的时间。我也不想浪费你的。所以我想接下来一段时间，我还是把重心放在其他事情和其他人身上吧。”说真的，你必须直截了当。把这当作一个礼貌的借口，从此停止回复，停止互动，甚至可以把他们设为静音，把他们的对话框移到Messenger或Instagram的“未读/隐藏”文件夹里。
create like some mental roadblocks so that if you want to talk to them, you have to consciously jump over some hurdles to basically get access to them. And hopefully those roadblocks serve as a reminder of like, hey, we're not doing this. We're not after this. We're walking away because you really need to reflect on what you want. You need to, after this point, really step back and realize that every loss is a lesson, even the small ones. Maybe you don't want to hear that right now, but instead of ruminating on the unanswered questions or the what-ifs, you really do have to shift the answer inward. You know, this experience has probably really taught you what you're actually after. And before you get back out there and start chatting to another person, especially if you're
给自己设置一些心理路障，这样每当你想要联系他们时，都必须清醒地跨越重重阻碍，才能真正联系到他们。希望这些路障能时刻提醒你：“嘿，我们不玩这一套了。我们不求这个。我们要转身离开。”因为你真的需要好好反思一下自己究竟想要什么。在这之后，你真的需要退后一步，意识到每一次失去都是一堂课，哪怕只是微不足道的失去。也许你现在并不想听到这些，但与其在那些没有答案的问题或无数个“如果”中反复纠结、反刍，你真的必须把关注点转向内心。你知道的，这次经历大概真的教会了你，你到底在追求什么。所以在你重新出发、开始和另一个人聊天之前，尤其是如果你本身就是
someone who gets invested very quickly, I really want you to reframe and reassess and reaffirm what you're after. It sounds like you're after someone who wants to freaking date you. So take this as a lesson as an important sign of why it's important to enforce boundaries, why it's important to be looking for someone who is going to take action and who wants to move things along. And I think know that you've saved yourself a lot of future pain from cutting it off now rather than waiting two, three, four, five more months, like, and then getting the shock of your life when you were even more attached. You know, it's also a case. to just straight up distract yourself. This person probably gave you a lot of dopamine. Potential
那种会迅速投入感情的人，我真的希望你能重新构架、重新评估并再次确认你到底想要什么。听起来，你是在寻找一个真正想跟你痛痛快快约会的人。所以，把这当成一堂课，当成一个重要的信号：为什么建立边界感如此重要，为什么寻找一个愿意付诸行动、推动关系发展的人如此重要。而且我认为，你现在及时斩断，而不是再等上两三个月甚至四五个月，免去了未来更多的痛苦，这时候你才遭遇当头棒喝——相比于那时，你其实已经拯救了自己。你知道的，这也是一个
is exciting. New beginnings are exciting. There's a lot of positive feelings that we're chasing here. Where can we cultivate that elsewhere? What can we pour out time and love into that isn't this person and isn't another person, something bigger. So if you're really feeling stuck in it, set a new goal, give back volunteer, foster a dog, foster a cat, go and do some dog walking, go and do some plant, some planting, some community garden work, like get out of your own mind and your own problems. Plan a weekend trip, get your friends together. Like there is nothing wrong with a bit of distraction.
直接转移注意力的好时机。这个人大概给你提供了大量的多巴胺。未知充满无限可能，
Sometimes you really do need that mental distance in order to integrate the experience. And also understand that it might be shitty for me to say this to you right now. This is an important part of your story. This loss is actually a gain. my friend Sophie said something to me the other day that I really love, which is that is someone else's person. And it didn't work out between you two because that was meant to be part of their story to find the person they're meant to be with. And when you meet the person you're meant to be with, you'll be thankful for all of their failed talking stages, all the ones they went to. you've got to be thankful because yes the world is sometimes disappointing but don't forget it's
有时候，你确实需要这种心理上的疏离感，才能将这段经历好好内化。同时也要明白，虽然我现在对你这么说可能会让你觉得有点扫兴，但这其实是你人生故事中极其重要的一部分。这种失去，实际上是一种获得。我的朋友索菲前几天对我说了一句话，我特别喜欢，她说：“那是属于别人的人。”你们俩没能走到最后，是因为那是他们各自人生剧本的一部分，是为了让他们最终找到自己命定的那个人。而当你遇到那个命中注定的人时，你会为他们所有那些失败的暧昧经历、所有他们经历过的过客心怀感激。你必须心怀感激，因为是的，这个世界有时确实会让人失望，但别忘了，它其实也
secretly working in your favour as well that failed talking stage has meant that that person found their one and it means that someone else's failed talking stage means that you guys are closer to meeting each other okay with that sentiment in mind we're going to take a short break but when we return let's discuss some of our really amazing listener questions about everything from whether the talking stage is different for lesbians, green flags in the talking stage, and whether the taxi cab theory is real. So stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
在暗中默默眷顾着你。那段失败的暧昧期，意味着对方终于找到了真爱；这意味着别人失败的暧昧期，意味着你们离彼此又更近了一步。好了，怀着这样的心情，我们要进行短暂的休息，但等我们回来后，让我们探讨一些非常精彩的听众提问，内容涵盖方方面面：从“女同性恋的暧昧期是否有所不同”，到“暧昧期的绿色信号（加分项）”，再到“出租车理论究竟是不是真的”。所以，请锁定节目。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to two percent. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我将剖析精神韧性、体能训练以及在这个奇妙的现代世界中构建心理弹性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人深入交流，带大家看透那些充斥在健康产业中、不切实际且过度复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你终将涅槃，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。搜索单词TWO percent，即可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill
或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么鬼关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important. years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast,
大谈80年代的快克（Crack）毒品。说实话，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊那天的快克，只要你们想听。我是说，马克，到目前为止，这已经是我们第二期讨论快克了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条清晰的主线了。我们现在甚至还把“艾滋病”摆上台面了，所以……谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的，我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了。
learn the hard way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
《知难而进》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将自己十多年来在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的精彩对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们执着于追求某样东西时，
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实早已拥有了它，却还在拼命追赶，甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着生活的记分牌，人生变成了一场场胜负的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上当个好人很重要，还是说你当好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test won. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
这也是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能纯粹地去当一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio App，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后举行的家庭法院听证会暴露出她故事中前后矛盾的惊天漏洞。这拉开了一场长达数年的法律战，只为了证明真相。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
你曾两次伪造这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我伪造了一份检测。这需要一大群互联网侦探联手才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露出了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样遭遇的男子——
Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Our first question, which I really should have addressed earlier, is what are actual green flags during the talking stage? I've got a couple. I think someone who asks questions, someone who asks questions, someone who replies in under 12 hours and even 12 hours is a bit of a stretch. You know, people are always on their phones. They want to talk to you. They will. Someone who is taking it somewhere.
格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，突发新闻。马里科帕县传来消息，劳拉·欧文斯已被正式指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义于亚利桑那州伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
There is movement. They are gauging your interest in plans. They are seeking your availability. They're saying, we should do these things and actually acting on that. Someone who isn't sharing too much too soon, I think is another green flag. You know, they're not trying to have all the big, dark, maybe deep conversations online. They're saving stuff for in person. And this one, some people might not agree with me, but someone who doesn't make comments about
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。我们的第一个问题——其实我早该回答了——在暧昧试探阶段，真正的绿色信号（加分项）到底有哪些？我总结了几个。我觉得，会主动提问的人，会主动提问的人，在12小时内回复消息的人（甚至12小时都有点勉强了，你知道的，大家手机都不离身，如果他们想跟你聊天，他们就会回）。那种会让关系有所进展的人，
your body or about sex during the talking stage, like, you don't even know this person yet. If they're being like, oh, we should do this and making comments about sexual things, I'm just like, no, this is not a good setup. So those are my green flag. but definitely someone who was like looking to get off the messaging on the dating app situation. This next question is the talking stage different for lesbians. I don't know.
关系是有在向前推进的。他们会试探你对约会议程的兴趣。他们会询问你的空闲时间。他们会说：“我们应该一起去干嘛干嘛”，并且真的付诸行动。我觉得另一个绿色信号是：不会过早分享太多私事的人。你知道的，他们不会试图在网上把所有重大、黑暗或深刻的话题一次性聊完。他们会把这些内容留到线下见面时再聊。还有这一点，有些人可能不同意我的看法，但那就是：在暧昧阶段，不会对你的身体或性事评头论足的人——讲真，你们俩甚至都还不认识。如果他们动不动就说“哦，我们应该这样那样”，并对你进行性暗示或评价，我心里只会想：“不，这开局可真糟糕。”所以，这些就是我的绿色信号。但毫无疑问，最核心的加分项还是那种急于结束线上聊天软件的暧昧、想要奔现的人。接下来的问题是：女同性恋的暧昧期会有所不同吗？我不知道。
So this question fascinated me. I had to do some digging. I had two things that I kind of came across. Women in general have more mirror neurons. That's why that's what makes us more empathetic, more often emotionally aware, especially when we combine that with social conditioning. You know, we are raised to be quite more communicative, to be more vulnerable, to be more open.
所以这个问题深深地吸引了我。我不得不做了一番深挖。我总结出了两点。总体而言，女性拥有更多的好大神经元。这就是为什么——正是这一点让我们更具同理心，更常具备情绪感知力，尤其是当我们把这一点与社会规训结合起来时。你知道的，我们从小接受的教育让我们更擅长沟通，更愿意展现脆弱，更开诚布公。
So maybe if it was two women who were dating, that would mean that they would be getting to the dating part sooner because they're probably going to be more direct and wanting to really connect with people. That was my first theory, which would make it different for lesbians. I was also thinking about the stereotype, which is that the very famous myth that lesbians commit sooner, they're moving faster, they have shorter talking stages.
所以，如果是一对女同性恋在约会，这或许意味着她们会更快地进入真正的约会阶段，因为她们可能更直白，并且非常渴望与人建立真正的连接。这是我的第一个理论，如果成立，那女同性恋的暧昧期确实会不同。我还想到了那个刻板印象——那个非常著名的神话，即女同性恋陷得更快、进展更快、暧昧期更短。
I did some digging on that. There's a very well-known study, actually, one that we really should be talking about more, from Stanford University, which found that lesbian couples do not shack up any faster than heterosexual pairs. This idea of the U-Haul lesbian of them moving in quicker, doing things quicker, is not supported by evidence. So with all that in mind, you know, I really didn't find any actual fundamental evidence for a difference in the talking stage for lesbians.
我对此进行了一番深挖。其实有一个非常知名、且我们真该多聊聊的研究，来自斯坦福大学，该研究发现：女同性恋伴侣搬到一起住的速度，并不比异性恋伴侣更快。所谓“女同性恋开着U-Haul卡车搬家”（指闪电同居）的说法，即她们搬家更快、行事更快的观念，并没有得到证据的支持。因此，综合所有这些来看，你知道的，我并没有发现任何实质性的根本证据，能证明女同性恋的暧昧期有什么不同。
Like there is nothing about them individually that's different from a heterosexual woman that is going to mean that this is different for them. That being said, I also know that the research community, the psychology community, a lot of the times, like they don't. They don't really consider individuals of different sexualities in their research. So there really is no way of knowing because no one's done any real research on this. So if you have a different opinion, if you have information that is different to what I've said or evidence to the contrary, let me know. And I'll do a little update on this because I think it would be fascinating to know. My main inclination is it's probably not different. like in general it's probably not different there might just be more individual differences that are
就她们个体而言，并没有什么地方与异性恋女性不同，会注定导致她们的暧昧期有所区别。话虽如此，我也知道研究界、心理学界很多时候，他们并不把不同性取向的个体纳入其研究考量中。所以真的无从知晓，因为根本没有人对此做过真正的研究。所以，如果你有不同的观点，如果你有与我所说相反的信息或相反的证据，请告诉我。我会对此做一个小更新，因为我觉得了解这一点会非常迷人。我个人的主要倾向是：它可能并没有什么不同。就像总体而言可能没什么不同一样，只不过在这些关系中，可能存在着更多个人差异，只是这些差异或许没有被拿出来广泛讨论罢了。我太喜欢接下来的这个问题了：如何在交友软件上保持兴趣？我经常不小心滑到很多人，因为这过程太无聊了。是的，往往之所以无聊，是因为没人回你消息，对吧？所以首先，稍微休息一下，从交友软件中抽身出来，做一次“约会排毒”。重新思考一下你的优先级：你在寻找一段恋爱关系吗？你在寻找一个开心的周六夜晚吗？你只是在寻找性吗？你必须清楚自己到底在追求什么，因为这会直接决定你的应对方式。当你重新回到交友软件上时，请带着明确的目的性。你右滑了多少人？你是不是只右滑了那些你真正喜欢的人？还是说，如果你只是在寻找一个开心的周六夜晚，你把所有人都右滑了？
noticeable within those relationships that perhaps aren't being talked about more i love this next question how do i stay interested on the apps i accidentally go so many people because it's so boring yeah often it's boring because no one is messaging you back right so firstly take a little break just take a step back to a dating detox rethink your priorities are you looking for a relationship, are you looking for a fun Saturday night, are you just looking for sex? You got to know what you're after because that's going to influence your approach. When you get back on the dating apps, be intentional. How many people are you swiping on? Are you only swiping on people you really like? Or if you're looking for just a fun Saturday night, are you swiping on everyone?
你在发消息时是直奔主题，还是希望对话能更自然地流淌？拿出你的能量来。我知道当遇到某些人像一堵油盐不进的砖墙时，这真的太难了。但我发现很有用、并且我一个目前正在约会的朋友前几天也在跟我讨论的一点是：她深知交友软件有时就是一场概率游戏，你必须身在其中，并且必须全情投入。所以她每天晚上都会清空自己的消息，花上区区10分钟回复每一个人，直到她开始注意到那些她真正想聊的人，或者直到某个人脱颖而出。她会觉得：“你知道吗？如果我想正儿八经地约会，并且想谈恋爱，我就必须对此采取一种系统化的方法。”而我的反应则是：“好吧，对，
Are you being really direct with your messages or are you looking for things to flow a little bit more? bring the energy and I know it's so hard when some people are just like a freaking brick wall but what I found useful and what a friend of mine who's currently dating was talking to me about the other day was that she knows dating apps are sometimes a numbers game and you just have to be in them and you just have to be committed to it so she clears her messages every evening so she spends just 10 minutes replying to everyone until she begins to notice the people she really wants to chat with or until someone stands out. She's like, you know what? If I want to date properly and I want to be in a relationship, I've got to be kind of systematic about it. And I'm like, okay, yeah,
那就去吧，就照这么干。”也许这、也许这就是正确的方法。也许这就是——你只需要投入和找工作时一模一样的精力，对吧？即使你收不到任何回复，你也必须坚持下去。但我永远支持你。我还想说，让你的朋友给你介绍对象。你永远猜不到。他们手里可能藏着什么秘密人选，是他们之前没跟你提过的，比如他们的同事，或者某个朋友的表哥的姐姐的弟弟。听起来有点近亲繁殖的意思，但你知道我的意思。总之，他们可能认识某个人。
go off, go like that. Maybe that's, maybe that's the way to do it. Maybe that's just, you just got to put in the energy the same way you do when you're looking for a job, right? And you don't get any replies back. You just got to keep going. But I'm rooting for you. I would also say, ask your friends to set you up with people. You never know. They might have someone sneaky. who they haven't told you about before, who they work with, or who's a brother of a friend of a cousin of a sister. That sounds kind of incesty, but you know what I mean. Like, they might know someone.
最后一个问题：“出租车理论”是真的吗？所以，“出租车理论”，你可能在TikTok上听过。我想它最初源自《欲望都市》（Sex and the City），我最近一直在重温这部剧，这或许就是我被这个问题吸引的原因。该理论的主角是男性。意思是，男性在他们人生中的某个特定阶段，脑海里的一盏灯会突然亮起，他们就准备好谈恋爱了。而一旦他们准备好谈恋爱了——就像只要你一准备好打车，你就会立马坐上你看到的辆出租车一样。
This final question, is the taxi cab theory real? So, taxi cab theory, you may have heard it on TikTok. I think it's originally from sex in the city, which I have been re-watching recently, which is perhaps why I was attracted to this question. And the theory is that it's about men. And it's that men essentially at some stage in their lives, this light goes on and they are ready for a relationship. And as soon as they are ready for a relationship, the same way, as soon as you are ready for a cab, you just get into the first one you see.
那段感情就是你的归宿，那辆车就是你的出租车。所以这个理论的核心观点是：男性花大量时间寻欢作乐、拒绝承诺，然后突然有一天，开关“啪”地一打开，他们就开始疯狂寻找恋爱关系，而遇到的第一个想要跟他们谈恋爱的人，就会成为他们的伴侣。事情就是这样运作的。我觉得这其实在某种程度上符合一些真实的心理学概念。
And that's your relationship. That's your cap. So the idea is that men spend all this time wanting to have fun, being uncommitted. and then one day a light will switch and that's when they go searching for the relationship, the first person they find who wants to be in a relationship with them. That's how it's going to work. I think it kind of aligns with some real concepts.
准备就绪理论（Readiness theory），也就是我们之前讨论过的“承诺准备度理论”。人们在自己准备好时才会做出承诺，而不一定是因为遇到了对的人。所以，时机确实很重要。这也与某些里程碑式的焦虑以及人们可能经历的焦虑、我们所有人都要面对的“承诺剧本”不谋而合。也就是那种恋爱剧本：“哦，我快到这个年纪了，我快35岁了，或者无论是什么年龄，
Readiness theory, the commitment readiness theory, which we talked about before. People commit when they are ready, not necessarily when they meet the right person. So yes, timing does matter. It also kind of aligns with some of that milestone, and anxiety someone might be experiencing, the commitment scripts that we all face, the dating scripts of, oh, I'm getting to, I'm getting up there, I'm getting to 35 or whatever age it is that
人们觉得真的需要有个伴儿了”，而这种社会压力可能会真正触发他们想要安定下来的决心。总的来说，我不认为它是真的。我觉得它把事情过分简单化了。我觉得它把男性塑成了恋爱关系的主导者，让他们掌控着自己身处其中的任何恋爱关系动态，我希望我们正在超越这种陈旧的观念。而且我认为，没有任何理由说明女性身上就不会发生同样的情况。我觉得本质上，这不关乎男性，不关乎女性，不关乎任何性别。我觉得这仅仅是因为：有些人确实到了某个阶段，他们准备好做出承诺了。他们真的会一头扎进看到的第段恋情吗？也许会。我觉得更准确的说法是，他们开始更认真地对待约会，他们不再
people feel they really need to have someone and that could really trigger them to settle down because of societal pressure. I, in general, don't think it's real. I think it oversimplifies things. I think it keeps putting men in charge of relationships and in control of any kind of relationship dynamic they find themselves in, which I hope we are evolving from that. And I also think there's no reason why that wouldn't be the same case for women as well. I think really it's not about men, it's not about women, it's not about any gender. I think it's just about the fact that some people do get to a stage where they are ready to commit. Do they necessarily jump into the first relationship they see? maybe I think it's more that they really start taking dating more seriously and they start
绞尽脑汁为自己“为什么不该约会”找借口，而是开始努力寻找“为什么应该约会”的理由。有些人可能会把这称之为“将就”。我觉得任何恋爱关系其实都需要某种程度的妥协，听起来确实挺像那么回事的。好了，以上就是我们解答这些问题的所有时间了，我可爱的听众们。如果你坚持听到了这里，请在评论区留下一个表情符号，表达一下目前约会带给你的真实感受。无论什么表情都可以，甚至都不需要解释。你最近的约会状态（vibe）情绪如何？如果你有朋友、亲戚或同事需要听听这一集，请转达给她/他们。也许他们能从中收获点什么。确保你在Instagram上关注了我：@That Psychology Podcast。我喜欢听你们提问。我喜欢听你们对这一集的看法，
not trying to find excuses for why they shouldn't date they start trying to find reasons why they should some people would call that settling I think any relationship kind of requires some kind of compromise that sounds like that so that's all we have time for for these questions my lovely listeners. If you have made it this far, put an emoji in the comments for how dating is currently making you feel. Whatever emoji, you don't even need to explain it. What's the mood of your dating vibe at the moment? If you have a friend, relative, colleague who needs to hear this episode, send it to them. Maybe they can get something out of it. Make sure you're following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. I love hearing your questions. I love hearing what you think about this episode,
所以我会在那边等你，和你分享更多幕后花絮以及即将举行的活动的公告。但在此之前，照顾好自己。对别人好点，对你自己也温柔点。祝你们好运，我身处暧昧阶段的勇敢士兵们。我们很快、很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
So I'll see you over there for even more behind the scenes content and kind of announcements on upcoming events as well. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle to yourself. Good luck, my brave soldiers in the talking phase. And we will talk. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all?
欢迎收听《知难而进》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的心路历程，进行那些在其他地方根本无法坦诚展开的深度对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人把西服当成铠甲穿在身上？它向世界释放出的信号是：老子可不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host care games. This space is about black men's experiences. having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast,
或各大播客平台收听《知难而进》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、体能训练以及在这个奇妙的现代世界中构建心理弹性的科学。
or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
经历一些艰难困苦，你终将涅槃，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。搜索单词TWO percent。即可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听。当一群女性发现
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover
她们竟然都和同一个滥情的海王（connoissex artist）约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我绝对要做他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他必须得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说：相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和而言是个大日子。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。
they've all dated the same prolific connoissex artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Lookback at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm a I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人历史年份了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Look Back At It》。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人呈现。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。